got your washer and dry I told you if
you sent the email thread
the city of three weeks so you see it on
the whole transaction
[Music]
welcome back to Ryan's wild
um wow great name all right
so welcome back to another awesome
episode of the careful boys and today we
finally have
I've got abandonment issues and Bart
just bounced on us we had no one day we
had so like one day let Nick explain
please okay and it was like an emergency
too Joe's too busy opening up a [__]
June Bean priorities yeah right taking
pictures on the beach and [__] I saw
what that fool's doing yeah dude he's
just drinking drinks on the beach like
okay that's why we got Colleen here
that's why Colleen is the feeling but
then yesterday Colleen wasn't even here
right Joe wasn't here you weren't here
you weren't here yesterday
yeah Nick you schedule it I didn't
schedule [__] yeah I don't do really
anything except show up chaotic intro
but yesterday we had we had a we just it
was all the boys and we were running the
show we had no bosses I don't think so
it was Lord of the Flies in here yeah we
[__] we were doing all kinds of stuff
just a chicken coop with all of our
heads cut off just we were hitting 40
minute videos Six Minutes whoa we did
hit a 30 minute didn't we yeah we did a
couple Vines
we definitely didn't go to GameStop yeah
what we did go to GameStop too you
weren't here our our lunch Adventures
are way cooler when you don't have to
walk GameStop over there yeah oh [__]
you guys drove they took me to the
Monterey Park Plaza you guys drove the
calories off dude we were at [__]
Jamba Juice we were at [__] boba time
oh let's go there today no dude
go on our walks all right we're going to
walk soon so where where the [__] were
you yesterday man why'd you leave us all
right so yesterday it's been pretty
crazy
um I'm kind of have to backtrack almost
like
eight nine months almost wow so eight
months ago on the video
[Laughter]
30 minutes all started in December of
2021. actually I did start then so
that's not nine months by the way that's
about again
so 11 months ago
um we put a down payment on the new
house that we're gonna move into sorry
and when in in like a lot of these like
newer communities they have to build
them so when you go it's like [__]
dirt on the ground so you got to build
them and then in the beginning of like
you know when you're buying a house is
like more like adult talk you have the
actual house and then you have like the
financing of the house right that's why
you hear the words like [__] alone or
escrow you hear all these like grown-up
terms mortgage mortgage [__] like
that [__] a whack-ass [__] taxes
property taxes [__] [__] like
that right boring [__] because you want
to just talk about the house
we got the house yeah
so you get the house right and then at
the same time simultaneously
FHA with these new homes if you finance
through the Builder because a lot of
These Guys these big companies they like
to do this they like to take money out
of one pocket and they put in their own
pocket on the other side so so if you
find it through with a builder they'll
waive all these fees which can be like
10 G's worth of fees you know what I
mean so a lot of people if they can
they'll try to buy the house through the
Builder's bank or the Builder's lender
so you're buying this it's like buying
uh I mean we do this all the time
actually it's like you buy a Honda car
and you're getting financed by Honda so
they're literally going oh here oh nice
and manual go this way it's like that so
houses same [__] right you do the
[__] financing part so the easy part
is buying the house you just have to
build it they gave you like all these
etas all the walls are gonna go up this
time it's gonna go up this time oh so
cool and then the financing part they
have to consistently like run their
taxes like for the last three years so
2019 20 20 21 20 21 and then they got to
check your financials all the time and
usually escrow is 21 days so if you buy
like a regular home like Anthony sells
me his house boom we go into escrow what
they're trying to do is just make sure
whatever money I'm gonna pay Anthony or
financing that I get it's not there's no
liens on it I'm not going through a
divorce no one's suing me that's the
whole point of escrow like hey I'm gonna
give Nick this money well let's put this
money and this controlled vacuum
accounts and then it's completely clear
of all legal [__] now this money goes to
Nick versus if it's because it's such a
big transaction versus if I buy
something off and I'm like hey here's
five G's oh [__] you know my baby's mom
or whatever or I [__] around like a
person over now I gotta owe that person
5gs it's nice to have two options yeah
baby mama or run a person over that's
that's what baby mama and the person ran
over two different people just in case
you're wondering what a day I'm happy
so that's what escrow is for escrow it's
technically like proof of funds proof of
financing they don't want to see you
doing this [__] right they don't want to
see you going like oh I need [__]
like 100 Grand let me take a hundred out
of JK and then here look I have 100
Grand guys I could buy his house because
then they're going to look at all your
financials and they'll go wait how come
this is you took 100 grand out of JK
last month and now you have a hundred
grand your account so they also want to
see your accounts are seasoned meaning
no movement for like three months so
it's a lot of like [__] really
analyzing all this [__] right so in the
beginning they have this pre-approval
process so that when it comes time to
approve everything like all the
alley-oops have already been set up and
let's just so in the beginning we're
doing all this work you get your [__]
CPA or financial person whatever
involved and you cover all the bases
from your credit score to your seasoned
accounts to your property to your uh
taxes and all that [__] so everything
was going smooth and then we've been
given this date of September 27th that
we're going to close meeting September
28th we'll probably get the keys and
we're really happy and we based our
entire lives around it JK shoots around
it uh I was supposed to be in Hawaii
with Joe helping him take pictures on
the beach
he had a whole slew of things that we
had planned podcast like ad reads I have
to do even though it's only like one
every month we have to do it they're
coming though we got one today we got
one today but there's all of these oh we
do yeah we do six so we have to do it
so yeah guys we're getting paid this
month so we got all these things that we
had to do and uh everything is usually
wrapped up within the first two weeks so
every other escrow process I've been
through if they're good it's all the
hard work heavy liftings in the first
two weeks and literally
um the next week or two is just checkups
everything's good everything's looking
good on September 26th the lady told me
hey can you send these documents over
and I'm like what the [__] so that to me
is almost as if like
um if you're about to get married and
the day before your your spouse is like
what's your name again right it's like
that oh no once you send the documents
over that means it hasn't even gone to
underwriting so they have to take that
document [__] balance it check all
that stuff and then so it's been the
date so that was like already a huge red
flag and even a week before I've been
checking out everything looks good right
let me know stop asking me for things
[__] piecemeal which I've said so
many times I don't know how many all
caps emails I've written [__] stop
asking for things peace meal like I see
see my financial uh uh advisor on here
don't even talk to me because you're
gonna ask me questions I don't [__]
know and they'll still keep asking me
and texting me and my [__] I
[__] told you this guy speaks [__]
dollar signs I don't speak dollar signs
and the whole [__] time uh up until
September 26th I'm like there's no
[__] way in hell because I've never
had escrow go past escrow boom 27 it
doesn't go through and they're still
asking for all this [__] [__] and
then so now like everyone that we have
that uh like Post House stuff like if
you want to get your washer and dryer
installed or like just things I need to
do with their house like landscapers
like you have the post getting the keys
you set all that [__] up now I have to
go through and call like 10 other people
and those guys are like just the
dominoes
gotta wash and dry here
yeah and I'm like I don't know bro I'm
like [__] they [__] I can't close I
don't even have a house like what are
you sitting around the car right now I'm
like so I feel bad for all these guys
too because all the [__] that's supposed
to come in is [__] sitting around for
I don't know in their living room for
like another three weeks and then
finally uh
my my agent was dope she was like kind
of could see how things were gonna wrap
up she's like you know what like if it
doesn't go by uh yesterday which is
October 17th it's gonna go another round
because what's going to happen is
tomorrow is the LA or yesterday was the
last last
um turn-in of business taxes so when you
do business taxes it's not due in April
it's actually doing October most people
file an extension so you can kind of
like draw out the cash flow
but if it passes yesterday then they're
gonna have to need a whole nother year
of taxes we're just gonna push my whole
[__] house [__] another like three
months oh no no writing [__] right
so
um my agent was like just come in just
set the time and then we'll just see
what happens I'm like okay that's smart
so that's what I have to I fly in
yesterday morning and literally at like
10 a.m I'm just sitting in front of the
escrow office I already text and I'm
like hey [__] I'm outside so if
you guys got everything squared away I'm
gonna go inside to sign hey guys today's
video is brought to you by Warby Parker
Warby Parker offers everything you need
for Happy Eyes eyeglasses
sunglasses contact lens
and eye exams and you can shop with them
online or in stores glasses start at 95
including prescription lenses try Warby
Parker's free home try on program order
five pairs of glasses to try on at home
for free there's no obligation to buy it
ships free and includes a free prepaid
shipping label try five free pairs of
glasses for free at warbyparker.com off
the Record so the try on kit makes it
super easy because when I ordered this I
was able to just pick the types that I
wanted to try first especially with my
kind of shape of face I want to be able
to see what it looks like in real life
and you know what some of these I like
some of them I'm not too sure you guys
be the judge should I keep this or
should I not but the best part of it is
it's free and I can return these and I'm
just like I don't want these I want to
try another five then I can do that you
can add a pair and save get 15 off when
you purchase two or more pairs of
prescription sunglasses or eyeglasses
and if you're like me and you prefer
shopping at stores Warby Parker has over
a hundred and ninety locations
nationwide so go to worryparker.com off
the Record to try five pairs of glasses
for free and then uh at 11 they still
couldn't sign and then finally one of
the ladies inside were nice they let us
in and
um they were still wrapping [__] up I've
[__] cut so many people out on the
phone which I never do that's not even
my style but it's just too crazy at this
point
and then uh they're like the absolute
deadline is 2 p.m Pacific Standard time
because I think how like the law Works
they need to receive like funds
um before a certain time Eastern yeah
for things to be stamped and cool this
is you did close on this date and we
don't need your next year's taxes and at
2 pm it hit and then we looked all at
like me ago [__] and the agent would
look at each other like
well [__] I guess it's gonna go on for
another [__] three months and uh the
lady that was super nice inside came
back out she's like hey you know what
I'm just gonna tell you what this never
[__] happens but I just uh wired it
at like 217 anyways
and I just submitted everything anyways
we'll see what happens and she was but
I've never seen in the history because
like Banks they they work on literally
down to the second you know they don't
[__] around and then um we're like all
right so we sat around and then little
by little like every single step there
was like little good news so she was
like one the wire got set out and I was
like when you mean sent out I'm like is
it like
or is it just like the lady was like
it's still in the
right
it's
[Laughter]
good that's one and then the next day
and she submitted and then like you have
to uh everything in terms of like
property you have to get it like
registered by the county so that like
you have documentation in case some [__]
happens like [__] let's say someone
comes in like kills my whole family at
once okay cool
um they have to know okay who does this
house belong to is it the baby Mama's uh
you know it could be we got you here but
you go to you go to like some sort of
public record and you know yeah in case
like everyone gets annihilated for some
reason okay
she's like I was able to register with
the county and I was like okay cool I
can imagine bar in these meetings is
like do I have to sign this just in case
everybody like gets an island
the lady's like yes just in case so that
got registered so you're saying if
everybody somebody comes and like
murders my whole family there's gonna be
a record of it thank you cool got it and
then they still brought the notary
person in you gotta sign like [__] a
whole phone book worth of [__] and then
they just took out the couple of pages
that are required after they receive
funds so just to like kind of expedite
everything you know so we signed all
that [__] it was just like one little
like Victory after another and then
finally the lady comes out and she goes
I don't know how it happened but they
received it and I was like what the [__]
that's crazy it never happens because it
got sent out at like 217 or whatever and
I'm like lady you're a [__] angel
she's a lady with the shortest bangs
I've ever seen
is that
is that what you told her that no I
don't know
it's like the shortest bangs I've ever
seen oh my God I just can't put his
finger up to him I've been wanting to
tell you the whole time I'm thinking
about it the whole time but her name's
Debbie and I was like shout outs to
Debbie you're [__] awesome and then
so finally they're like okay cool the
house is yours out there there's no
going backwards from here because during
the whole process there would be like
one two three four five and then the
next email is starts at two and I'm like
wait what I already sent all these
documents oh no we gotta bounce to this
person and the random people just
introduce themselves in an email thread
and I'm like who the [__] are you it's
just it was like a [__] [__] show I
think I got your washer and dry I told
you
[Laughter]
he's waiting
why you go through yet
I'm over here waiting your driveway I
got your Whirlpool come on there's only
third on the slide eh
yeah I think because of Labor shortage
like companies will like um Outsource to
other companies that Outsource to other
companies so you have like so no one
really has answers when I call and I ask
a question they don't know what's going
on though I'm waiting for answers too
I'm like you're just climbing the ladder
you're being the one that [__] knows
what the [__] so you can't even be mad
at the right guy right no yeah I'll tell
you we were mad at the right guy dude
this guy at what point did he call you
when you were in that office oh yeah
what was going on oh that's a good
question yeah where did we come in we
Face we FaceTime Bart while we were
about to shoot we're a little anxiety
yeah and then we saw that you were in
some office and then you said someone
told you to shush or something oh it's
Gino yeah that was what time did you
call me called you right before right
after lunch because Kevin was about to
come in yeah so like oh so that was like
yeah yeah that's probably right here
yeah so you're waiting for the wireless
I [__] I hope it goes through hope it
goes through holy [__] what the [__]
yeah it's like Bart can you talk right
now he's like uh yeah I was like
this is either a [__] prank or they
need help I don't know why Anthony's
calling me that's what we said you were
gone we're like man is this a test dude
the test bar did you are you really just
outside waiting for us to just buckle
down you know like damn yeah dude so we
got the keys yesterday which is super
cool but it's not even like one of those
where like Yay it's more of the uh no
the wind doesn't feel like a NBA Finals
like you won by 20 points the the win is
I mean the feeling is the pl the team
you're playing they shoot the
game-winning three and everyone's like
oh and then the ref's like but wait
let's check the tapes and then go back
and check the tapes and they're like
wait there's a couple things that were
wrong he was stepping in front of like
the three-point line oh that was this oh
this guy [__] double dribbled or
whatever and then so they're like you
win and then you're like okay wait
that's a cooler win than 20-point lead I
would
I would rather win like that no you want
to win by domination yeah I feel like
you're just in overtime right now it's
not even a solidified when yeah until
like you have the key during overtime
but you went overtime so long that
everybody left the [__] Stadium
nobody's watching you anymore and you're
like man oh yeah it's like on a
technicality except the washer dryer guy
he's exactly like this
so they're like zooming in on the
[__] lit backboard and like
like which came first the [__] band
or the ball they're just can you keep
doing that but uh
how about a more horizontal
congratulations
you know what though I do really enjoy
you explaining stuff because you know a
lot of stuff that you're going through
with like buying a house and going
through all that is very scary and
intimidating but the way you explain it
with sound effects and like in ways that
I can understand I'm like I think um I
understand how this works it's like
buying a house for dummies audible it is
scary though there's a lot of [__] on
there I bet on the papers and stuff
you're just signing oh this is [__]
whatever whatever I'm like I guess I
just trust you
yeah I'm not gonna read it they're like
we didn't either it's all good yeah
because you this you bought how many
houses before like it's like our fourth
one fourth house and nothing close to
this has ever happened ever escrow is
usually like
um and they they say ours is like the
most chaotic usually because like if
you're like a W-2 like you're a nurse or
something that's the easiest you get
like one set of [__] financials and
it's super clean cut it's literally like
companies will look at it Go Boop proved
you know especially one of those jobs or
industries that are super steady like
ours it's like they go like yeah how
many companies you have and they're like
well actually our companies have
companies so like there's bottle Brigade
gyms supplements apparel wait how come
Michelle's how come the show is like the
gym uh lost money this year and also
because the gym was loaning apparel to
do this to fund this thing oh so they
have to cross reference yeah so I'm like
technically didn't lose money you're
just playing the game of money you know
and then so they're like looking at [__]
and they're like wait I don't even
understand what the [__] going on
so and this is also one of the things I
think what happens when you work with
the builders lender they're used to W2s
like most people that step into like
that are going through a Chase or a
Wells Fargo like the big like big box
lenders they're used to cookie cutter
financials yeah so that's why like
there's a lot of these Boutique
companies like men from what's a
mortgage he'll be way faster because
he's used to dealing with like crazy
[__] and like they won't get stumped
over something right like one of the
things was uh yesterday I was yelling at
the guy on the phone for he goes like oh
man this guy the way this guy talks to
is so [__] annoying
don't talks like this and everything is
dragged out for no reason so he's like
he's the movie phone guy yeah so he
calls and he's like so um and this is
already me like just just I'm like hurry
the [__] up he's like so
um the insurance uh on your house uh
looks like the rate went up and I'm like
no [__] [__] because when we got a
rate like appraisal back in December
it's 2022 now
I thought you would be part of your
process to get updated rates right
because it's [__] October and he goes
like so it looks like it went up and I'm
like yeah it's [__] October that's
why I said on the phone and then he's
like so what it looks like is uh
uh your monthly is 57 more every month
and I was like you're gonna
over 57 [__] oh my God I'll tell you
what the next six years worth of
insurance I'll pay it all right now
I just did not talk to you get to the
other side and she's like whoa whoa whoa
well we can't we don't have the
authority he's like you're a very fast
talker
like it's October yeah I was on the
phone with them like um oh that grinds
my gear I like 145 right where we knew
that cut off was two at 145 I'm like yo
where's everything at what the [__]
the hold up cause I got the insurance
thing over finally like I just called
give me the [__] number give me the
number I'm like text me what you want me
to say verbatim because I don't [__]
speak Insurance either
he text
forever so he texted me verbatim and
then I called the insurance lady surely
she was awesome too shots Shirley and I
just read the phone I was like Hey
Shirley so this is what they want and
then I just said exactly that and I was
like can you get that over in like 15
minutes she's like yeah I'll do it I'm
like cool so that was taken care of and
then uh I thought it would since it was
15 minutes I thought he'd be able to
expedite things but then an hour later
still nothing happened so now it's like
1 45 and then I'm like uh excuse me like
what the [__] going on like what's the
hold up you said it's only going to take
15 minutes now it's been an hour and he
goes and it's a 145 he goes yeah so uh I
can I can see that
I can see you you only have 15 minutes
left I'm like dude I want to [__]
choke the phone oh my god
get his name
[Laughter]
I think that's how they're smart they
put people in different offices in
different locations yeah so you can't
just storm into an office so you can't
just annihilate everyone in once you
can't annihilate yeah
damn they didn't need to fire that guy
you look so happy to buy your fourth
house
[Laughter]
[Music]